utah senator mitt romney with some
strong words for homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas blasting
the biden administration for its
handling of the crisis at our southern
border watch
what i find astounding astonishing mr
chairman
is that we have the secretary
responsible for securing our border
and our immigration system who doesn't
recognize these charts as being a
problem
and there are human beings behind these
numbers and it is not saying hey we've
got to make some changes immediately
i find that i find that extraordinary
and and
extremely damning myorkis says the
administration
can meet the challenge at the southern
border but he also went on to blame the
trump administration for the massive
surge happening there
with us now our next guest sharing brand
new images of the crisis the border
these pictures in a moment will show
drugs and migrants
stuffed into semi trucks at the border
there's also a video too that shows
migrants driving by troopers
who had stopped another car want to
bring lieutenant christopher alaveras
texas department of public safety
welcome back sir to our program here and
good morning
the first images i want to share and you
can explain this to
it's a semi truck inside you found 105
illegals and 171 pounds of marijuana
what happened there yes bill good
morning thanks for having me again so
uh one of those photos that you're
seeing there our dps trooper did an
outstanding job
in stopping that commercial vehicle
which resulted in 105 migrants that were
stuck inside that trailer
that was just great work by our dps
troopers and as we approach the
the summer heat we know that smuggling
of these migrants and vehicles and
vehicles such as a
as a commercial vehicle it's high risk
it's dangerous
and going back to the other photo where
we're showing the narcotics with
migrants
these smuggling organizations these
cartels are also
smuggling migrants across at the same
time they're smuggling narcotics as well
and trying to use that as a distraction
for law enforcement
it's happening all the time every day in
fact i
got a few videos right now the first one
is a trooper that goes to pull a car
over
when it stops the illegals get out and
run away
and then there's another video here that
shows the smugglers trying to get other
people
into their vehicles explain both sir
yes sir so the first video with our dps
trooper
stopping a vehicle that's that's on a
major highway one of the primary
highways that leads
to the ports of entry to the checkpoints
in the rio grande valley
and that highway will lead to other
cities houston dallas san antonio
and this particular couple and that
vehicle came down from the houston area
with the sole purpose to smuggle
migrants from the rio grande valley
to houston because it is being
advertised on social media but again our
dps trooper was
there at the right time did an
outstanding job and was able to recover
those uh big migrants i believe at that
time
and arrested the driver and the female
passenger for smuggling
wow just so i can keep this clear
there's another video i want to play
that now
smuggler's using to get people what does
that mean
what happened here sir so that
particular video you have a smuggler
who's pretty much
very bold in what he's doing and
advertising and showcasing his criminal
activity on social media
by driving by a trooper who was stopped
with another vehicle
and then showcasing that he's smuggling
my migrants inside his vehicle
as he drives by the the trooper so
that's very bold for those smugglers to
to show that activity and to post it on
social media
certainly is happens every day doesn't
lieutenant
and for how much longer it's not slowing
up no it's not slowing down bill
it's it's not slowing down it's going to
continue to increase and the numbers
show it
and uh we're doing the best we can to
provide the resources for our federal
partners